[Music]
in fair pay news mm-hmm
submitted by I love TIF and geo oh
thanks that's very nice of you guys it
is very very nice give it to a guy Oh
tip Angie oh yeah yes gobble time yep
a London firm is now letting its staff
set their own salaries okay a million
dollars a year yeah exactly that's what
I would sit 1.5 do you think if you did
that people will take advantage of it
yes well I kind of like their system
because what they're doing is they have
like a patron spirit transparency policy
where they pretty much upload this on
some sort of platform where everyone can
see and you get to have people vouch for
you so let's say like and I say like oh
you know I feel like I deserve this much
or whatever then you guys can be like oh
yeah she deserves or like nah but
everyone sees everything so that's cool
that's pretty dope I like that I think
that's a bad idea just because there's
also office politics and there's people
who hate people just because they hate
that's true so oh yeah but then they'll
see that everyone sees everything so
it's like super transparent even though
there are out of office politics and
then there could be favoritism - oh yeah
at least everyone sees so you see
everybody's comments if it's like I want
a 20 thousand dollar raised you all
weigh in and you'd be like the only
person to be like she sucks and then I
would know you said yeah yeah that's
type also you can't lie that's pretty
cool what everyone's gonna know you're
lying
yeah but what about conversations
outside them there's collusion like if
me and TIFF for friends we could be like
hey let's vote for each other and just
you know type in doubt you know give me
give each other good word cuz kind of
like what I've learned about people is
just like I don't I feel like if people
can get an edge up on something they'll
just do it other than good or bad person
or not look at the way I play games
survival yeah yeah I don't look I'm
trying to win yeah I think that's the
world I think it's a pretty cool idea
cuz I feel like a lot of people they
they inflate their self-worth and they
feel like they're really entitled so
it's like man I should be making like 10
G's
month and then you look up and you're
like always so the hardest-working guys
is you should only make this much I
think it helps people suffer evaluator
yeah cuz we are not so aware yeah so
this company here it's a London firm and
the company is called market which is a
betting markets a betting exchange
company so I guess they exchanged bets
or something
anyway the point is here that they're
saying that if your team like their team
communicates really well like they have
a great company environment and so
they're saying that this process
probably not going to work if your
company already doesn't have that that's
well yeah thinking yeah it works yeah I
think if everyone was like in it
together then you could have a really
constructive conversation and then
people will kind of like lift each other
up but if I'm just so used to a toxic
work environment that you know Matt JK
but like throughout my work experience
everything is always the same office
politics rules all like people don't get
you know upgraded I'll merit yeah it's
kind of like because you kiss-ass to the
manager you make them feel good so
they're gonna give you you know a raise
or whatever but there's other people
that are really busting their ass but
they don't socialize so they don't rise
up the ramp popular they're not talking
you ever get this yeah but they're the
ones really carrying the company and I
saw that [ __ ] I'm like that sucks
yeah and especially right now in Britain
where there's like a lot of disputes
over executives earnings and like gender
pay gaps and all this stuff that's why
they decided to implement this new
system and it seems like it's been
working so far you know they make like a
clear I guess like if the company can
communicate clearly if you do these
things this is valuable to us then you
will get a raise then people don't have
to make fill in the blanks on their own
and be like you're getting paid more cuz
you're a man you're getting paid more
like whatever you know if if so for
example Paolo the woman and then I felt
that something unfair was going on
I would try to look at how much money I
made for the company and I'd be like
look last year I made two [ __ ]
million for you guys
all these [ __ ] didn't make that much
but they're getting more what's going on
if you need me pay me more you know like
that's my value but since none of that
is spelled out
no one knows everyone's just guessing
well I spend so much time here or like I
did so many you know things but like
your if your work isn't valued by the
company like what your efforts it
doesn't equal dollars or whatever it is
you could just be thinking I'm putting
so much effort in okay they don't want
to tell you they're not qualitative yeah
I mean you could yeah yeah cuz I think
this is already in practice like with
the NBA you know what the top guys make
you know what the Benchwarmers make and
you know I also know their field goal
percentage there's like how many assists
points they saw yeah it's really hard
like if you're like I don't need a
hundred million dollars a year and it's
like well Kobe Bryant who makes all the
points isn't getting this they're like
oh I should probably shut the hell up
because I'm tripping okay oh sorry and I
think that's really cool too because
right now we're kind of in like this
climate of like everyone should be
treated fairly like you don't want to
ask anyone like like let's all be PC
that's all be occlusive and stuff but
that's just not practical and that's
just not how the real world works you
know so I've heard of like CEOs and
stuff that do that that are just like
alright this person deserves more just
cuz they're better and they kind of get
[ __ ] for that but I'm like no like you
just said it like there's players that
have their stats out there and you
understand because he's better than you
you know way that there's a way to
quantify it - yeah Joe saying if it's
not just left up to assumption but if
you're like okay this person like if
there's a way to measure their
productivity so even if you're like wait
how come tips only spending 20 hours a
week I barely see her but then if you
see her output it's like crazy high
that's the reason why she doesn't have
to be there that much and she can make
this much money good just by owning so
many different companies right it
doesn't matter if you're man woman
old young it's all about output and how
much you know how efficient you are how
much money you make for the company so
I don't understand the whole like why do
people pay women less it doesn't make
any sense to me why is there all this
stuff it might be politics maybe it's
different when it's like a huge publicly
traded company and the way because all
of our [ __ ] is mom-and-pop so for me all
I see is value by individual you bring
in a lot of money for this company your
efforts are good you also help 10 other
people because you're so helpful
whatever it's like of course they should
get paid more and most people like on
top they want to pay people good because
they don't want them them yeah at the
highest level if you guys are top
performing employees people will come
and poach you don't ya don't ya men and
male and female but if you're not gating
poach or people aren't coming up to you
there's a reason why it's cuz you suck
yeah that's probably why yeah same I
mean if I think performance speaks
volumes and if it's open up exactly what
you said though it has to be in a place
where your business is ready for that
and you know people already they're not
cutthroat and they're not like well
they're not a team anyway if camaraderie
is there then it'll be fair playing
ground it's an even playing field but if
not then you kind of you're kind of
[ __ ]
yeah it depends on company culture
because there's people that are raping
the company from inside out like the
CEOs are coming in jackin they don't
give a damn about the employees the
employees are like what's in it for me
no one cares about the customers
everyone's just going into places yeah
and there are company cultures like that
so if you're in a toxic environment like
that oh man Wow yeah that wouldn't work
yeah it seems like they have a really
cool company culture at this market
because markets it's like smart markets
yeah smart marketing because they they
have a team of chefs that come in and
make lunch every day what most able
video games to keep staff happy they
take your applications that's a good can
we say we got a ping-pong table and a
basketball shooting pinging yeah what is
that you know huh yeah we I love our
company we have like I think we have a
really great company culture here at
Genki because we always were like family
oh not
it's not all business it's like we're
actually care about yeah sometimes like
Barton Joe beats us up to is pretty cool
I never be true that part just comes in
any [ __ ] Spanx Bishop I know we're
family we [ __ ] I was just saying that
this is my first time interacting with
you all as a group and I think the
company culture is very nice it's feel
very welcomed and loved you don't see
the chains underneath the desks yeah no
I can't leave this chair
you mean this one twice and I want to
see you suck your own dick
I'll take yoga and take you up on that
offer I think like I thought you were
honestly gonna step in it's not
your timing was just a little off on
that one you've always been that's what
you can use the pause that's where you
need it to sputter I think working
through a lot of toxic environments I
always I I just like ask myself like why
the [ __ ] does the world have to be this
way I think most people just accept it
as this is the way it is you're gonna
you all jobs are like this where you you
do shady people and all that and I was
like nah dude it doesn't have to be that
way
a lot of mom-and-pop seem to fail in my
personal opinion because of a personal
ego and price so when like for example
there's a friend of mine works at a
business right now and they had somebody
come in that was an expert at helping
manage like gyms and stuff right so they
worked at some of the top gyms house has
helped me form and expanded them out he
comes in and this guy is like I guess
like he's doing really well for himself
so he was like you know what I'm just
gonna come in now to teach you guys how
to make this a profiting like business
model and that dude he came in they
hired him and they fired in the next day
cuz he said he overstepped his bounds
because he's saying like your trees
supposed to be a man exactly like you're
hiring him for his expertise so he
wanted to be a gym manager and teach
them how to expand this out into
something bigger and more profitable
because according to them they were
saying that they were just barely
getting by and so he goes okay well this
is what you can do and he's like you're
overstepping your bounds and you're
trying to take over my gym but that's
what happened and this is a story I just
heard the other day and he goes like and
that's like a big problem that a lot of
mom-and-pops have they don't see things
beyond themselves in their own identity
so even sometimes when employees have
ideas they go you're overstepping your
balance but it's like you can't that
could be a great idea you should always
listen and not everybody has that so
it's it's such a different like level of
work and world to on the executive level
versus like the employee level and I
think a lot of people just see those
numbers like oh half a million or like
you're making a million a year that's a
lot of money it's not fair for the guy
that's making 60,000 but take it from me
you do not want to be at that level that
level is full of [ __ ] alien
Arlis crazy the most nastiest [ __ ]
individuals on earth and it's like do
you really want to work 80 hours and
have failed marriages and link it's not
a balanced lifestyle to me I'm always
like who's crazy enough to do these kind
of jobs like why do you want to be
executive why the [ __ ] that's crazy
that's insane I think it's a control
control thing there's B they're the kind
of guys that light candles up their
asses and that's it get it lit with a
ball gag and they get smacked because
they need to feel submissive yeah yeah
they're those kind of guys but see
candlelit dinners real quick
[Music]
[Music]